عموم الكلمة اليونانية لجميع theos
greek لكل الآلهة كل الآلهة
لا أحد يعرف سبب إعطاء هذا الاسم
لأقدم مبنى مستخدم في العالم ،
ولكن ربما يكون مناسبًا من ناحية واحدة ،
يمكن أن يكون البانثيون في روما هو الأقرب
الذي يمتلكه الإنسان.  تعال إلى
الخلود ،
يشعر أي شخص يخطو داخل البانثيون على الفور
بالثقل الساحق للتاريخ البشري ، ولكن
أيضًا الخفة
المذهلة للإبداع البشري
في عام 2019 ، زار تسعة ملايين شخص
البانثيون ، وكان الموقع الأكثر زيارة في
إيطاليا ، ولم يكن المبنى اليوم هو الأول
كان هناك اثنان من البانثيون هنا قبله وكلاهما
محترق مما أدى إلى فكرة أن
المبنى كان ملعونًا
المبنى الذي يقف الآن ، وقد تم الانتهاء منه
حوالي 125 ميلاديًا من قبل الإمبراطور هادريان
الذي صنع أيضًا جدار هادريان
ولكن ما تم استخدام البانثيون من
أجله بعيد  من المعابد الرومانية كانت
عبارة عن هياكل متعددة الأغراض ، وبالتالي فإن ما
حدث بالفعل في البانثيون من الصعب أن نقول إن
إحدى النظريات تشير إلى المكان الذي كان فيه
الإمبراطور ج.  شارك مع زملائه
الآلهة في مقهى للخالدين
يدعي آخر أنه كان موقعًا مقدسًا حيث
صعد رومولوس مؤسس روما إلى الجنة
ليصبح الإله
كيرينوس ، وكان أيضًا رمزًا مهمًا جدًا
للقوة الإمبراطورية
التي جلبت القوة المواد من جميع
أنحاء الإمبراطورية الرومانية
الجرانيت من مصر الرخام الأبيض من
الرخام الأصفر اليوناني من الرخام التونسي
الأرجواني والأسود من تركيا
والأهم من ذلك كله
هو المادة الأكثر دفئًا التي
اخترعها الرومان
[موسيقى]
هذه قبة البانثيون التي تتوج في
قمتها بقطر 30 قدمًا
وتفتح على  السماوات ،
لا تزال القبة أكبر قبة خرسانية غير مدعمة
في العالم
، وهي أيضًا نصف كرة مثالي بطول 142 قدمًا ،
وكانت القبة بارعة جدًا لدرجة
أنها كانت تعتبر في العصور الوسطى من
عمل الشيطان
لأنه لم يكن بوسع أي
إنسان أن يصنعها أطلق عليها مايكل أنجلو
الملائكي وليس
الإنسان ، أوكلوس الذي يعني أنني
مبتهج ، أعتقد دائمًا أنه أحد
الأماكن القليلة
في العالم التي يمكنك الذهاب إليها  ويمكنك في
الواقع مشاهدة الأرض وهي
تدور لأنه يمكنك في الواقع رؤية الشمس
وهي
تتحرك عبر شبكة القبة
التي قد تبدو جيدة الآن ، لكن
البانثيون تعرض للنهب والنهب من قبل
الأباطرة البيزنطيين والباباوات الكاثوليك
على
حد سواء ذهبوا  هو البرونز
من السقف والسقف ،
لكن أسلوب المبنى يوجه
التصميم حتى يومنا هذا ،
فإن البانتيون هو إنشاء
واختراع القبة في العمارة الغربية
الكلاسيكية الجديدة ، وهو أسلوب معماري
يحاكي تلك السمات اليونانية والرومانية الشهيرة
مثل الأعمدة
والتصميمات الهندسية والمثلثة
كانت الأقواس كبيرة جدًا في القرنين الثامن
عشر والتاسع عشر لا سيما
في المملكة المتحدة والولايات المتحدة الأمريكية ، لقد وضعت قبة كبيرة
ربما أعمدة كبيرة أمامها وهذا
يشير إلى أن هذا مبنى جاد ومهم
ولكن ما يقوله أيضًا هو أننا على
دراية بالبانثيون
ويجب أن تكون أيضًا قد تم
بناؤها من قبل المستبدين ولكنها اليوم تقف
كرمز للتعليم
والحكومة والفنون  السفينة ، إنها
مجرد
جرأة مستحيلة ، روما هي
المدينة الأبدية ، لذا
مع تقنية البناء المثالية هذه وبالاهتمام الذي
نقدمه لها يمكن أن تكون
ملائكية أبدية وليست بشرية